john why do you love character driven
films
i think it goes back to when i was a kid
and i would watch movies in theaters or
sometimes even things i saw on
television
and i would get so involved with these
characters and you know i grew up in
brooklyn kind of a working-class
neighborhood
so any opportunity that i had to
be transported you know out of that into
a different world with people i didn't
know anything about i was always very
interested in that
but the most important thing for me
i think that inspired me most
was those moments in the theater
where i would sit there and recognize
something in a character that i
recognized from myself
and i realized i'm not alone um and that
to me was the single most powerful thing
that bonded me to storytelling and to
movies and very early on i thought to
myself
i would love to make someone feel that
way i would love to tell a story that
someone sits there and goes oh wow
that's me that's my family
uh i'm okay you know there's nothing
wrong with me i'm not a misfit there's
somebody else
so that's really why i love it so much
and i've always tried to
everything i do i try to make sure it's
informed with
you know interesting characters and and
and you know some depth and
and an arc you know of somewhere to go
do you remember those first few movies
that you saw wherever you were in new
york
i do i'm embarrassed to admit it but the
first
movie i saw my mother took me to
at the lowe's oriental in brooklyn
and it was called madame x joan crawford
and um you know as i remember the plot
uh
she had to give up her baby
uh you know when she was a young woman
and then years later she gets accused of
murder
and she finds this lawyer to defend her
and it's her son you know
and it was so uh
fraught with you know emotion if i saw
it today it was probably too much
emotion i don't know maybe too
sentimental but i was so you know i was
probably like eight or nine when i saw
that film
and first just being in a movie theater
i was so wow this is like so transported
as already you know the curtains opened
and i just felt the hair my neck go up
and um and i was very very emotionally
affected by that movie and on the bus
going back to our apartment in brooklyn
i started to cry
and i said to my mother because at the
end i guess she never revealed herself
to her son
and so the secret remained and and i
began don't ever leave me you know
um
so yeah i think that that was one of the
first movies i saw that really
um made me feel
uh very powerfully
attracted to this idea of telling
stories
that's a great story
yeah and i saw another movie on tv this
was um if you remember the old hallmark
hall of fame
uh before that whole
brand was kind of deluded by the
hallmark channel
but the hallmark hall of fame was like
the prestige television in the 50s and
60s and all the way up to fairly
recently
and there was a tv production of arthur
miller's the price
with george c scott and barry sullivan
and
it was about these two brothers who came
to their father's house their father
just passed away
and they had to split up the stuff and
there was a
interesting character who was there too
i guess he was like a
i don't know if he's a pawn broker but
he was somebody who was going to sell
and buy this stuff
and uh
it was a great um
you know i think georgie scott was a
brother who'd become a cop and the other
brother it was a more white-collar guy
and one had left and one states the care
of the father so all these great injury
fight your family dynamics
and again i was very young when i saw
that film i couldn't have been much more
than 11 or so i guess
but i was again just so struck by
the the truth that i saw in these
relationships
and and the the raw emotion and the way
the actors you know performed it i was
just so
completely taken away by it
and i have to say just then going ahead
many years
uh i was thrilled when i got to direct
my first hallmark hall of fame
and i was telling when they hired me i
said you have no idea the history i have
with your show you know
how it was one of the things that
inspired me
uh you know to to be a director or be a
writer director and tell stories
what does it mean to understand your
characters
well i think as a writer for me it comes
first from
writing characters that you recognize
um
there might be combinations of people
you know
[Music]
either you know personally or
people you imagine
uh and oftentimes for me i think most
writers there are aspects of yourself
that you put into character
um so
i i really feel like that that is the
most important thing in storytelling is
the character and
uh it's one of the things i always tell
students
who are starting out in film
because so many
young people
starting out and i was one of them many
many years ago but i felt and a lot of
the young people feel very enamored with
the with the technology
it's all about the lenses and what can
be done in the digital effects in it and
the characters get lost
and
so i always try to emphasize to students
how important it is to be observant
of the world around you
um to try to understand the people you
see like you know i'm just i live in new
york so
i'm a great student of behavior uh just
to go on the subway and sit there and
watch people
it's fascinating you know i never get
bored if i have to meet somebody on a
street corner and they're late it's fine
because it's just a show going on
everywhere i look
and i think it's really important to
attune yourself to that and also your
ear for dialogue to listen to the way
people speak how they express themselves
what are they really saying
what's the subtext what's going on
underneath what they're saying
and so i feel like those are things that
i
urge students to
expose themselves to
not only in in real life but also in
literature and theater and music you
know not just watch movies all the time
because then you're just really making
movies that are influenced by other
movies um
you know going back to something like
the
my heroes in the old hollywood days you
know the john ford and sean houston and
orson well all these fabulous
storytellers
preston sturgis
and all of their work was so full of
quirky interesting real characters
and those
those filmmakers all had
really rich
interesting lives before they ever
became filmmakers and even john huston
who obviously came from film royalty his
father was walter houston
but even he had left hollywood and he
was a boxer he was a newspaper reporter
he was homeless for a great deal of time
so when he came back to make his movies
he brought with it
this depth of knowledge about life and
people
and so um
uh
that's what i really feel is so
important for people to and because know
the the technology of it uh it's it's
fantastic
but as a director your job is simply to
know
what the story you want to tell is
and how you want to see it
and it's really somebody else's job
to now execute that which doesn't mean
that you you give up any control
but you know when i was first starting
out i was lucky enough to kind of tweak
to that early on
so instead of trying to figure out oh no
how would this shot work how can i
possibly see this guy come from here and
then go over there all in the same shot
i would just sit down with the dp the
director of photography and say here's
what i want to see you know i take this
guy out of the thing and we follow him
in here and then we bring him up here
how do we do that
and then they'll find a way
so then after 35 years you know you you
get to know how you have to ask anymore
you get to do it but i do think that's
something i always tell students is that
don't be so intimidated by the
technology or so enamored of it that
you're frozen uh in the other areas that
are so important about storytelling
because if you surround yourself with
really talented people
you get a great assistant director you
get a great you know camera person um
fantastic sound crew a script supervisor
who's really smart those people will
help you they'll they'll guide you
through as long as you let them you're
respectful and you let them know that
you need their help
um but your job is to focus on your
vision and what you want to see and then
they'll help you figure out how to
actually see it
i love too what you said about like uh
public uh transportation i grew up
taking the bus everywhere as well yeah
and it is a fascinating i mean you can
meet some great people and some scary
ones too but some great people that'll
just open up even the bus drivers will
tell you everything you know yeah and
you can really just soak in life public
libraries things like that yeah and it's
funny because when i do come to los
angeles
uh usually i'm here for a limited amount
of time
and you know i'm always driving
everywhere i go
and there are some days where i'm doing
multiple meetings
where i realize wow i have not even
touched the air today i've gone from my
hotel to the garage the car
to another garage another office back
there and so
at the end of the day i have not even
you know haven't even been outside
and so i always find that um i used to
worry about living here if i ever lived
here full-time
that sense of being cut off a little bit
from
life around you uh and in new york of
course that's impossible you know you
can't you have to just stay in your
apartment there but everywhere you go
stores
uh the streets just teaming with drama
you know all around you in fact i always
do this thing on my twitter feed where i
every now and again i'll put overheard
and i'll come up with a little piece of
dialogue that i that i just happen to
hear
it's great you know i got you not long
ago i heard somebody just walking by me
on their cell phone and they said i just
heard them saying i'm all out of body
bags check with me in march
oh gosh that's great where does that
come from oh my god professional autopsy
is that right
so uh
it's great to just try to stay in tune
with what's going on around you and be a
you know be of sponge i'll tell people
that it won't even be conscious at a
certain point as you're writing
that these things you have observed and
absorbed just start to seep
seep into it and you start to see these
characters and
hear them
and you'll start to hear these familiar
voices oh yeah yeah this is that guy i
know who this is you know always the
greatest moment in writing any writer
will say this you know it's not my
original thing but the greatest moment
either in a script or in a you know
fiction
um
when the characters start to rebel
against you
and you you you have a plan you're gonna
go hit this where we're going with the
story this is what's happening and
suddenly as you're writing it
you could just feel like it's just not
working they're resisting it they don't
want to go in this direction
and they want to go this way and and
then i'll follow them now
and you know when that doesn't happen
all the time but when it does it's just
like golden and that's where a good
understanding of character really
really helps you out
and is that your signal to you that this
is this is the right direction with this
like i know this is a real character now
absolutely and it's frustrating
sometimes because you realize oh no i've
been on the wrong path
for the whole first act of this the
script and now i found the right path
great but now i gotta go back and
rewrite everything but you know you
still it's a gift and and you know you
you just take it uh but yeah once that
if that happens to me then i realize oh
yes
i'm now i'm in the zone
and now the characters are telling me
what they want to do
so they've come to life they're they're
real now and i pay attention
are there times when the characters fall
flat and you feel there is no resistance
and then you realize
should i cut this character or do i need
to really work on who this is
yeah there are moments where
you know there's always that deadly
thing where i feel like
i know what this character is going to
say next
and that's you can't have that you know
you just cannot you don't want to be in
a situation where the character starts
to say something
and now okay we all know what the rest
of that sentence is going to be so when
that starts happening a lot then i have
to kind of sit down and just rethink
that character
but i will say
oftentimes
there's a trap there's a danger in that
as well because it can stop you
you know in the middle of your story in
the middle of your work it's like okay
now i've got to stop i figure so what i
tend to do
is i just go through the script
start to finish
and get it done and as i'm going i know
okay this isn't right this is not going
to be this is i'm going to have to work
on this
but i'm not going to stop now because
then i may never finish i may just get
bogged down on this who knows how long
and i'm going to learn things about the
rest of the story as i go along even
though it's not quite right yet
so i will do everything i can i i try to
even read like come down in the morning
to work i don't even read what i wrote
yesterday because i'll just get bogged
down i'll start to fix it i'll start to
worry about it
i just want to get that words on paper
that sort of vomit
out of that of the story
and then once that's done that's a huge
step
and then i go back and now that's when
the real writing begins
uh once that first draft is done and i
can go back in and i try to take a
little rest from it i have people read
it my wife melissa peltier is you know
just brilliant with story and everything
else in the world
and um uh she will give me great
feedback about what works what doesn't
work and
and so once you've had little outside uh
eyes on on the material
then you can go back in and start to
really mold it and shape it and
leave on the second draft to say i do
the same with every draft i don't stop i
just keep going
uh even when i know
i'm going to throw this out i'm going to
probably throw this entire second act
but i got to keep going to get to the
end and then i'll start over again